now I can show you the picture of this I
can show you the picture of this but the
answer is not what you're interested in
or the answer shouldn't be what you're
interested in what you should be
interested is how we going to mentally
walk through this thing and get a
picture for it okay so therefore what
I'm going to do is draw with me one two
three four four little axes okay which
we're going to use to develop slowly the
idea of what this thing should look like
okay four little axes like this one two
three four and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to build this step by step I'm
going to build a step by step and this
is the way that I'm encouraging you to
think about it because it won't do for
me just to land on the air so I want you
to understand the way I think about it
so to begin with I'm going to think
about log base two of X so I just want
to think about this guy normally and
we're pretty comfortable with this idea
right we know what the basic shape looks
like we know where the asymptote is and
we also know where the one only
intercept is so far so good
but now what I want to do is add layers
of complexity until I get to this thing
so the first thing that gets changed
again like brackets you start close in
and then you move further out the first
thing that gets changed it is this minus
one right that's a shift what direction
is it in it's to the right its
horizontally because mucking with the X
and that minus one tells it goes that
way so what that does is it changes
excuse me the asymptote it's no longer
at x equals zero now it's at x equals
one and it also changes the intercept
which is no longer out one it's now at
two and that's it that's all that's
changed this is log base two of X minus
one I'm going to continue expanding out
what's the next thing that changes if
this minus sign isn't it right so what
effect is that minus sign have on the
whole thing it's a vertical flip isn't
it right because actually what it's
affecting is this f of X the whole thing
so therefore this vertical asymptote if
you flip that upside down it's still
where it is at x equals one
and if you look at the intercepts if you
flip that upside down well it's still at
the same spot all that changes is the
stuff around it are you ok with that
so this guy here is log so minus log
base 2 of X minus 1 you happy and I know
where that is
ok lastly now and I'm actually really
draw this thing I'm going to add to what
effect does that have on the graph it
shifts that vertically up two units
right when you take this guy here right
where is that going to go this vocal
asymptote it's going to be in the exact
same spot because it goes on forever so
now that this is my last graph I'm
actually going to label it okay the
question very helpfully it even reminds
you hey give me two points with the
exact coordinates it reminds you that's
an important thing to put on the graph
okay now safely we already have one of
those points because look you told me
for this one the x intercept was two
well this whole thing is going to move
up two units right so that is no longer
to be going to be 2 comma 0 it's going
to be 2 comma 2 so that looks like two
color - to me are you happy with that
and that shape is going to continue
going like that so I've got one point
I'm going to need some other information
here so now I need to know where that is
how do I work out that this is an x
intercept the normal way i find x
intercept is by letting y equal 0 so or
f of x equals y so if I say that then
minus log base 2 of X minus 1 equals
negative 2 log base 2 of X minus 1
equals 2 so I want to help me out here
very good
so X is going to be 4 plus 1 ok with
that
so my scale is not the greatest but that
is a point okay
and that's actually 5 comma 0 so I'm
home I'm done dialing my asymptotes yeah
no let me just double-check
happy times now if you wanted because
some people don't classify that as a
point you could add one more on you've
got 2 comma 2 & 5 comma zero one other
point would you like pick a point any
point x equals four so all you have to
do is is check that in here I'm going to
suggest that x equals four is going to
be fine but it's a hard value to choose
because you'll get 4 minus 1 which is 3
that's gross I don't want to do log base
2 or 3 so instead I'm going to choose
this you see why that's more useful
because I'm going to get F of 3 being
minus log base 2 of 2 that's handy plus
2 this is minus 1 plus 2 this is 1